GEORGE MOUNT: Hi.
I'm George Mount from the
Android UI Toolkit Team,
and I'm here to tell you about
the new Activity Transitions
API that we're releasing
in the L Developer preview.
But before we get to
Activity Transitions,
let's talk a little
bit about transitions.
Transitions help give
continuity to the user.
In this app, I have buttons
on the left and on the right.
And when the user clicks on a
button, something is happening,
but it isn't clear what.
Now using the Transitions
API, released in KitKat,
it only takes a
few lines of code,
and it becomes clear to
the user that the buttons
are moving between the columns.
The Transitions API is great
when working with layouts,
but what can we do
between activities?
The default Activity Transition
has a scale and fade effect.
I slowed down the
transitions on my phone
so that they are easier to see.
We can customize Activity
Transitions with, for example,
a fade.
We can also do a scale,
slide, or rotate,
but they work against
the entire window
and don't give the user the
continuity we really want.
For the new Activity
Transitions API,
if we wanted this
continuity, we had
to create this transition
all on our own.
Here we have an
activity, Activity A,
with a little yellow view
that we want to transition
into the new activity.
Now, in the old way
of doing things,
the first thing we had to do was
capture the size and position
of the shared element.
Next, we started the
activity, passing the location
in the intent.
Our new activity,
Activity B, had
to start as a translucent window
with a transparent background.
It also had to prevent
the default scale
and fade transition.
The shared element view
was then sized and placed
in the position
passed in the intent.
The background
was then faded in,
and the shared
element could then
transition to its
final location.
And then the rest of
our UI could come in.
Wow.
That's a lot of work.
Let's see how we do it with the
new Activity Transitions API.
Here I have contact group with
all of my handsome coworkers.
When I click on an
image, it will bring up
the detailed contact
information in another activity.
I'd like to share
the contact image
to draw the user between
the two activities.
Because I can have any
number of shared elements,
I need to name each
of them in my contract
between my activities.
I only have one,
and I have given it
the name "Contact Image."
To tell the framework which
view is going to be the shared
element, I give the
image a name also.
I've named it the
same thing, so I
don't need any code to glue
the contract name to my shared
element.
I also want the shared element
coming back to the grid,
so I name that element as well.
I then just launch it with
an activity options bundle.
Let's see what it looks like.
It looks nice,
and we didn't have
to do any of that hard work.
When the orientation
changes, the shared element
picks up the final position
from the calling activity
and restores it to
the right place.
Amazing.
My activities were doing a
subtle fade-in of the views
other than the shared element.
I'd like something a
little more dramatic.
Let's set the
entering transition
to use a nice slide effect
so all the other views enter
from the bottom.
Previously, the calling
activity didn't have any effect.
I like to have the views
around the shared element
leave with an explode animation.
Let's see what it looks like.
The views from the
calling activity
push out from the
scene, while the views
from the entering
activity slide up.
I can also make the
transition even more dramatic
by having the entering activity
wait for the calling activity
to finish before it slides in.
Now that you've
seen how easy it is
to add continuity
between your activities,
I know that you
are going to want
to add activity transitions
to your applications.
Make sure to check out
more of our DevBytes
and the rest of our I/O videos.
Thanks very much for watching.